make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
let me tell y'all man let me tell y'all
read a story that was so good you want
to punch a hole in the wall that's
exactly what this says
do if God were writing comic books right
now is what it would look like right now
okay so this story picks up in the year
3000 and 19 and dr. manhattan's just
like okay so basically like the earth is
gonna be threatened in like a guy you
know tries to protect it and basically
dies or the process but the crazy thing
is like energy of this guy let's soft
basically like Sims arene careening back
through time right and then dr.
Manhattan's going through and he's like
okay so like it's basically like the the
cascading effect right like he's like
okay this guy exists because of the fact
that Alan Scott exists right but like I
move the lantern out of the way Alan
Scott never became the original Green
Lantern which myth that Alan Scott never
founded the original JSA which made like
this Legion of super-heroes never
existed like is literally just kind of
analyzing the effects of his own actions
but remember because everything that's
going on dr. Manhattan cannot see the
end of all things and he doesn't know if
that's because of the fact that he gets
killed by Superman or dr. Manhattan
destroys everything in reality so it's
kind of the coolest thing and so
remember this comes after firestorm had
basically like let off this massive
explosion in Russia which it was kind of
tricked into more or less and then
interned like the world kind of turning
against superheroes more so than they
already were because those are guys who
were just kind of catching up or those
you guys haven't read this
the Superman conspiracy is the on
running theme and Doomsday Clock the
idea that like there's this conspiracy
running around dead like all superheroes
or almost all superheroes were created
by America by the American government
and so with the explosion that happened
in Russia and all the other superheroes
basically kind of banding together what
we end up finding out here is that like
everyone has come together and when I
say everyone I mean like everyone like
the Justice League Odyssey team the
Justice League of America like all the
magic wielders all the super all the
members of the Superman family like
everyone is here and everybody's try to
figure out what in the heck is going on
and so it's kind of it's it's it's
amazing here because while all that
happens like you literally have like dr.
Manhattan who's just kind of musing to
himself he knows exactly what's gonna
take place but he's just kind of musing
to himself with like everything that's
going on with regards to like earth and
the superheroes and so on and so forth
so detached and not really concerned
about akin is going on it's just kind of
there like I wonder what'll happen next
and really just kind of concern about
like why he can't see the future and
it's kind of nuts because like while
of course Superman's recovering Batman
recovering they were both in like the
immediate vicinity of the explosion but
then like Lois Lane goes running to his
side right and like that's really what's
kind of going on is like all these
themes are effectively coming to a head
but that you've got the President of the
United States being addressed by like
his cabinet basically being told because
the explosion in Russia by firestorm
fire storms of metahuman the Superman
conspiracy is already running strong
people already distrust superhumans you
have to do the only thing you can do if
you want to keep the White House they're
basically kind of asking him do you want
to be political or do you want to be
moral you can't be both and so the
president chooses or at least it seems
like he chooses to be political their
argument the argument of his cabinet is
you have to stand against metahumans
because that's what the general public
wants and at the end of the day you're a
servant of the people you have to do
what the people want you to do that
people want you to basically enact or at
least present legislation to Congress
that forces metahumans to reveal their
identities that basically removes the
ability for people to have mass it's
Watchmen all over again and it's so cool
here because then in turn you basically
have like Bruce Wayne waking up inside
Wayne Manor and you know force like
dread addressing Alfred and so on and so
forth all these things are kind of
happening at like a really really fast
clip and that's one of the things people
tend to forget and somebody actually
made a comment about this on Twitter
which is true that one of the things
people tend to forget about the Watchmen
is that it was it was a slow build right
like it was like the slowest story ever
until you get to the second act and then
things pop off but basically what Batman
essentially says here like a dress like
talking to Alfred is like what's going
on because the humanity has taken all
that all the various superheroes who
were essentially like traveling out to
Mars because that's basically what's
happening like what Batman explains here
is that like after a whole event with
firestorm did like the source of energy
that seemed to basically cause firestorm
to explode or at least was deduced to
believed to cause firestorm to explode
it's coming from Mars and that's where
all the superheroes are going they're
all going to confront dr. Manhattan and
so with Batman and Superman being the
only two left behind on earth alongside
Wonder Woman and I guess Green Arrow is
that what's basically going on is he's
like look I don't know if that energy
signature coming from Mars is the one
that actually caused all this I don't
know if that's what's really going on
there is a massive energy signature out
there and it does warrant being
investigated but like I think the
Justice League is getting played and
it's kind of crazy because that it that
in turn Mesa khalil Eve's the entire
earth vacated it leaves the entire earth
empty and so in in response to this like
Batman is like we need to send a message
off to them
kind of cool to see this because when
this happens we kind of transition over
to like everybody but Batman Superman
and like Wonder Woman but like when they
arrive on Mars it's all the Green
Lantern's it's it's the whole nine yard
is the whole kit and caboodle and this
is awesome thing because while that
happens you've got Lois Lane standing
over like the hospitalized body of
Superman in the Hall of Justice and it's
just this voice that comes out of
nowhere this is hello Lois and it's Lex
Luthor and it's like okay so like Lex
Luthor's making a move now
that was my thought my thought was like
okay so Lex Luthor is basically gonna
like kill Superman now but he's in a
super weakened state and Lois Lois
Lane's like you don't have a chance
you're not pulling this off it's crazy I
mean like Ronnie Raymond firestorm is
still alive they're in separate bodies
they kind of have to merge in order to
pull off whatever it is that they want
to pull off but still like Ronnie
Raymond kind of a CG Martin Stein and
saying look like we have to reform his
firestorm we're almost like a reality
where we can remedy realized matter like
there's almost no limit to our power
whatsoever like we have to basically
work together here the Green Lantern's
great like this giant field around Mars
but all these steps are being taken by
all these different these different
individuals here to like safeguard
themselves is this huge buildup
everybody's preparing for like a massive
battle against like this one guy but the
first one to speak up and talk is Jon
Jones well we're all like hey who are
you and what are you doing why you here
like let him scan like I've got stuff to
do but as basically kind of his response
is like hey man like you know look guys
like it's cool you're here but like I've
got bigger fish to fry besides you and
that's that's what's that's what's so
interesting about that is how like
dismissive
dr. Manhattan is of like Dean of the
veritable who's who because everyone is
here everyone but the villains are here
like every single superhero on earth is
here and like dr. Manhattan is just
dismissive and we find out why quick
fast and in a hurry it's so cool because
Guy Gardner the Green Lantern steps up
and it's just like okay hey look man
here's the rub it seems like you've done
some pretty shady things so before
before you make a move I want you to
understand what it is you're getting
into we've crushed all kinds of people
Darkseid the anti-monitor
are multiversal threat some evil
versions of Batman evil versions of
Superman
we've beat the Sinestro Corps we've beat
doomsday we beat all those all those
guys
dr. Manhattan addresses Jon Jones says
the reason why he's worried about me is
because he's worried about this one
vision he can get from me which is my
final view of Superman like Superman
racing towards me and trying to kill me
and so it's kind of nuts because like as
things go on
supergirl respond she's like so you
think Superman's gonna kill you so you
want to kill him first
like firestorm freaks out because he
thinks dr. Manhattan's been screwing
with him and cause him to blow up the
guy gardener just wants to fight some
stuff so he's like okay come on let's do
this he punches dr. Manhattan knocks him
out and the Manhattan vanishes reappears
behind him and destroys his ring and
it's like the coolest thing because he's
like let me remind you of your place in
the bigger picture he's just like bad I
like like just crazy like I'm curious
this ring that you way or has power
inside of it and while I'm not there
with like the slightest bit worried
about it I am curious about it it's so
like let's just take it and it's just
like this is interesting like I know
she's kind of like I found it difficult
to affect but here's the funny thing
about this right like it's not dr.
Manhattan in try hard mode this dr.
Manhattan in like laid-back mode let's
just casually destroy some things and
they're like all the magic wielders bust
out he's just kind of like this is
interesting you guys think you're really
magic because you're not really wielding
magic there's no real magic here there's
just you basically using reality warping
on a small scale but only able to
control what's left of the universe you
guys are able to cure it you guys are
able to manipulate the leftovers of the
universe just like you're the leftovers
of the superhero community who's talking
some mad trash in one fell swoop he's
just like boom and just and just since
I'm all flaunt these guys were
ill-equipped to deal with the power of
dr. Manhattan that's exactly what this
is now kind of switching back over to to
Lex Luthor for a second so he brings
something up here he basically says like
I'm the one who gave you all the footage
of like the heroes who are supposed to
exist like the JSA that we're supposed
to exist I'm the one who leaked it all
to you all the evidence that I have
points to this man that the Justice
League is basically going after who's
essentially like been meddling with the
timestream and then the Asscher question
he says have you ever heard of someone
named Wally West now this is big because
remember iris West
Barry Allen and hit Wally West Kid Flash
they're really the only ones who know
but is only like a very small number of
people who know about Wally West Lex
Luthor is kind of spilling the beans to
Lois Lane and basically saying like
here's everything that's going on now
this is where things get interesting and
probably we're like the old-school
Watchmen fans will get a little pissy
but what happens here is like firestorm
jumps in goes to attack dr. Manhattan
says like you don't know who you're
facing off against in Manhattan's like
no you don't know who you're facing off
against and this is when things get a
little strange because what seems to
happen here is dr. Manhattan Yanks
Ronnie Raymond into the past that's kind
of a big caveat here because as I
understand
when it comes to dr. Manhattan he moves
forward in time at the same rate as
everybody else dr. Manhattan cannot
travel back and forth through time the
thing that dr. Manhattan does as he
perceives all moments in time happening
at that moment in time right but like
today's Wednesday
and it's March 6 so for dr. Manhattan
today's Wednesday and it's March 6 but
is also every day that will come after
and every day that came before but
tomorrow
dr. Manhattan will be in March 7th dr.
Manhattan cannot jump back to March 6
from 2018 he can't really like
time-travel in traditional sense yet
seems to be the case with his character
he doesn't really perceive it in a
linear fashion but he cannot travel back
and forth through it Isola Cana seems to
be hinting at the idea or at the very
least outright stating dr. Manhattan can
time travel and what this is designed to
do is to kinda play mind games with
Ronnie Raymond but at the same time kind
of like retail its origin to a degree
the idea that instead of Martin Stein
and Ronnie Raymond kind of bonding
together in an accident that it was
intentionally done that it was literally
done in a way to where Martin Stein
wanted to create a character like this
and he needed someone who would most
likely bond to him and so ultimately he
chose Ronnie Raymond because Ronnie
Raymond one reminded Martin Stein of his
own son and too was in need of a
parental figure and what this does is it
reshapes everything it literally changes
the way that Ronnie Raymond views
himself and views Martin Stein and
almost kind of like sends amount of War
past which he does but he literally like
freaks out and he has up attacking dr.
Manhattan now this is when things kind
of shift back and that's when the
perspective that that's really when
Geoff Johns I think kind of clarifies
things that were we would look at that
initial encounter we would say okay so I
guess dr. Manhattan can time travel
that's not what happened presumably what
seems to have happened is that in the
blink of an eye
dr. Manhattan basically sent them on or
at least gave Ronnie Raymond like a
portion of his power and essentially
like rowdy Raymond saw time and the same
way dr. Manhattan does but instead of
seeing everything happening at once he
basically isolated to a single
perspective or a single point in time so
in reality they never left the present
it's just that how writing Raymond saw
time basically meant that like in his
mind's eye he was looking at seven years
ago to his own origin how it was that he
came into existence and the basis behind
his creation and is kind of cool because
when Ronnie Raymond attacks like the
rest of the Justice were really the rest
of the superhero community takes it as
their chance to make their move and like
the whole battle pops off and like
everyone is in this right like all the
Green Lantern's Supergirl the entire
Shazam family they all basically
channeled it into dr. Manhattan this
massive explosion goes off and dr.
Manhattan basically seems to die the
entire superhero community
presumably kills dr. Manhattan and while
that goes on like all these different
things are happening at the same time
like Wonder Woman's making her address
to the United Nations
you've got Lee the superhero community
that's celebrating the fact that they
killed dr. Manhattan the message Batman
wanted to send to them to tell them they
were being played was like basically it
failed to send and then Wonder Woman's
met from nowhere and dr. Manhattan
reconstitutes himself and literally in
one fell swoop defeats the entirety of
the superhero community with a wave of
his hand they're all gone and that was
kind of solidifying the fact that dr.
Manhattan was just playing games it
wasn't dr. Manhattan fighting to kill it
was dr. Manhattan being curious but like
he's not curious anymore be gone and
like they're all like they're all out
like that's basically it not only that
when Wonder Woman's making her address
because of the fact that all the
superheroes superheroes have left Earth
you literally have like Black Adam and
the villains who essentially like make
their move on earth it's the coolest
thing like it's one of the coolest
things ever because right now protecting
Earth you've got Wonder Woman Batman and
and Superman
literally Superman is gonna focus on
document hat we know that because of
Manhattan's vision Wonder Woman I guess
is gonna be left to defend the earth by
yourself because Batman's gonna race off
as well it's awesome like it is it's one
of the coolest things though would that
be said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you